Is the connection between us
and the universe. Through light,
we can experience distant stars and
look back at the beginning of existence
itself,
but what is light
in a nutshell is the smallest quantity
of energy that can be transported a Futon
and elementary particle
without a real size.
The combi split Oh me created or
destroyed light also has a wave particle
duality being kind of a particle
and a wave at the same time,
although this is a lie, so when we say
night, we actually mean visible light,
which is a tiny part of the
electromagnetic spectrum energy in form of
electromagnetic radiation.
Electromagnetic radiation consists of
an enormous range of wavelengths and
frequencies.
Gamma rays have the smallest wave lengths
because they're the highest energy
photons, but most gamma rays
are just under 10 pick a meters,
which is still way smaller than
a hydrogen atom. For reference,
a hydrogen atom compared to a scent is
about as big as a scent compared to the
moon. Visible light is in the middle of
the spectrum in the range of about 400
nanometers to 700 enemies.
It's about the size of bacteria.
On the other end of the spectrum,
radio waves can be up to
100 kilometers in diameter.
While the biggest wave lengths we know
exist can span from 10,000 kilometers to
a baffling 100,000 kilometers, way larger
than earth. From a physics standpoint,
all these different waves are the same.
They all have the wave particle
duality and travel at sea.
The speed of light just at different
frequencies. So what makes it visible?
Lights especial special then?
Well, absolutely nothing.
We just happened to have evolved eyes
that are good at registering exactly this
part of the electromagnetic spectrum.
This is not a complete coincidence though.
Visible light is the only
set of electromagnetic
radiation that propagates wet
in water,
which happens to be where most eyes
first evolved millions of years ago.
That was a smart move because light
not only interacts with matter,
it's also altered by it and can be used
to gather information about the world
around us with almost no delay,
which is arguably really
helpful for survival. Okay.
Where does light come from? A vast range
of electromagnetic waves are created.
When atoms or molecules drop from a
higher state of energy to a lower one,
they lose energy and a message in the form
of radiation at the microscopic level,
visible lines is created when an electron
within anatomy that is in an excited
state, drugs to a lower energy state
and losers. This excess energy,
the same way incoming light can activate
an electron to a higher state of energy
by being absorbed by it.
Macroscopically.
The moving charge of the electron
creates an oscillating magnet field which
creates an oscillating electric
field perpendicular to it.
These two fields move
themselves through space,
transferring energy from
one place to another,
carrying information about its place of
creation with why of all the things in
the universe is light. The fastest thing
there is, let's change the question.
What is the fastest way to
travel to space in the universe?
It's see exactly 299 million,
792,458 meters per second in a vacuum.
1 billion kilometers per hour.
Electromagnetic radiation just
happens to move this fast.
Any particle that has no massive travels
at sea without acceleration or any in
between.
The light that's being released from a
candle does not speed up until it reaches
lightspeed at the very instant of
its creation. It speed is. See,
so why is c or the speed
of light finite then? Well,
nobody knows. Oh, universities
just built this way.
We don't have a smart answer here.
So light is a part of a spectrum and
elementary particle that also behaves like
a wave propelled by two perpendicular
fields traveling at the speed limit of the
universe. Okay, that's nice and all.
But what about all the crazy stuff about
traveling at the speed of light and
time, the twin paradox contem
stuff and things like that.
We have to save them for another
video. For now, let's just be happy.
There'll be evolved eyes that pickup
waves of information permeating the
universe, making a c things that help us
to put our existence into perspective.
Okay.